the thing i don't understand about the
suicide person
is the people that try and commit
suicide for some reason
they don't die and then that's it they
stop trying
why why don't they just keep trying what
has changed is their life any better now
no in fact it's worse because now they
found out
here's one more thing you stink at
okay that's why these people don't
succeed at life to begin with
because they give up too easy i say
pills don't work try a rope
car won't start in the garage get a
tune-up
you know what i mean there's nothing
more rewarding than reaching a goal
you've set for yourself
[Music]
suicide it's the coward's way out right
every time someone kills themselves they
go he took the cowards way out is all he
did suicide is
for cowards who don't want to deal with
their problems so they want an
easy fix and an easy solution [ __ ] you
first of all life life is like
animal porn it's not for everybody
it isn't it's sad when kids kill
themselves because
kids didn't really give life a chance
but life is like a movie
if you've sat through more than half of
it and it's sucked
every second so far chances are it's not
going to get
great right at the very end and make it
all worthwhile no one should blame you
for walking out early
every time someone kills himself he took
the cow if it were a coward's way out
everyone would be doing it come on how
many brave people do you really know
there'd be no more root canals or
irs audits aids
test no i've seen the chicks you [ __ ]
take the cowards way out on alabama
you don't even want to know i
ask you to dance man [ __ ] you you ask
you to dance
well you're the one who keeps looking at
her if you don't look at it why don't
you go over and ask her
well fine i will go ask her then you
dick
hi i was sitting over there and i was
wondering
you know maybe on the next slow song or
something if
you wanted to dance or unless that's
your boyfriend
i'm sorry i'm just not really good at
this
oh he took the coward's way out
clarence is a [ __ ]
i knew he was gonna chicken out and blow
his head off dude he's a [ __ ] he
wouldn't even do a shot with us and
[ __ ] homo
life is precious too
to you you're young you're [ __ ] a few
dollars in your pocket your [ __ ] going
on
sell that life is precious [ __ ] to the
90 year old guy graveyard
shift at the nursing home he's moaning
with dementia
can't even recognize his own children
anymore
got big floppy hangy penis
lips from 10 years of catheterization
oh life is precious yes
turn me oh
i savor every sunrise
could you empty my bag it's leaking on
the blanket
the only reason he hasn't killed himself
is he can't figure out a way to do it
with pudding
[Applause]
this is a nursing home story this is a
little over a year ago
was in sarasota florida they found an 87
year old woman
dead in her bed in a nursing home with
1625
ant bites on her body ants and someone
had to count those
and that [ __ ] about my job
ants how do you explain that one to the
grandkids huh
no no honey nana's not with us anymore
sweetie p no
no see see god decided that he loved
nana so much he wanted her right there
in heaven with him
yeah so he sent an
army of fire ants to tear through the
dry wall
and then slowly chew her to death where
she lay there defenseless and unable to
scream
good night
mommy will god send fire ants for me
someday
only if you're good only if you're good
and you pray
every day then jesus sends the bugs for
you
good night who's got you in the belly
do you realize that right this second
right now somewhere around the world
some guy is getting ready to kill
himself
isn't that great isn't that great
did you ever stop and think about that
kind of [ __ ]
i do it's fun
and it's interesting and it's true right
this second
some guy is getting ready to bite the
big bazooka
because statistics show that every year
a million
people commit suicide a million
that's 2 800 a day
that's one every 30 seconds
there goes another guy
and i say guy say guy because men are
four times more likely than women to
commit suicide
even though women attempted more so men
are better at it
that's something else you gals will want
to be working on
well if you want to be truly equal
you're going to have to start taking
your own lives in greater numbers
but yeah
but i just think it's interesting to
know interesting
that's a big word in this show for me
interesting to know that at any moment
the odds are good that some guy is
dragging a chair across the garage floor
trying to get it right underneath that
ceiling beam wouldn't want to be too far
off center
if it's worth doing it's worth doing
right
somewhere else another guy has gone over
and getting a gun out of a dresser
drawer
somebody else is opening up a brand new
package of razor blades
maybe struggling with the cellophane a
little bit you know oh [ __ ] it's always
something god damn it
[Applause]
i just think that's interesting is hail
that's probably the most interesting
thing you can do with your life
end it i don't think i could do that
though could you
god i couldn't commit suicide if my life
depended on
but i understand it you know i think i
do i don't wonder about it i don't
wonder why'd he do that or was going
through his mind
you know what i wonder where'd he find a
[ __ ] time
who's got time to be committing suicide
aren't you busy i got [ __ ] to do
suicide would be way down on my list
probably down past lighting my own house
on fire
i might want to try a little
self-mutilation first
you know take a couple of hunks out of
my arm
see if i like the general idea
because you got to have priorities man
you know and you got to have a plan
too for something like that got to plan
that [ __ ] people don't just run out the
house and jump off a bridge
there are things you have to decide
timing is important when you're going to
do it
well let me see now
wednesday's out got to take timmy to the
circus
survivors on on thursday
friday i got my colon cleansing
folks are coming over on sunday
sunday bye guys that'd be just
a thing maybe mom will find my body
serve her right for [ __ ] me up the
way she did
then you have to pick a method how are
you going to do it
well afraid of heights that's no good
can't swallow pills don't like the side
of blood
[ __ ] ovens or electric
a lie down in front of a train except
the amtrak can come through here in 30
god damn years
maybe i'll just take a gun and shoot
myself in the mouth
uh suppose i missed
people be laughing at me suppose i live
i have a big [ __ ] hole in my head
i have to wear some kind of dumb ass hat
well i guess i just hanged myself that'd
be good
got to get a rope oh [ __ ] it's always
something
i got a rope in the garage ah it's got a
lot of grease and paint on it
i don't want to get this stuff on my
neck
walmart's having a special on rope this
weekend
no sense spent a lot of money to kill
myself then again i can always put it on
my credit card i'll never have to pay
the [ __ ] ning
that's it then i'm hanging myself in
walmart's paying for it
what's next a note
oh jesus gotta express myself
hell if i could express myself i want to
be thinking of doing something like this
where's a pen you never
find a pen i told the kids not to move
the pen away from that telephone
goddamn kids well let's just kill them
too
make one um family package deal
ah here's ben hut is jamming into my
[ __ ] neck and get it over it
let's see now where do you put the date
upper left
i can never remember that to whom it may
concern
ah sounds kind of impersonal
dear marzelle
leaves out the kids i know hey guys
guess what
keep on reading how are you i hope you
are fine
i am not fine
as you can no doubt tell from me hanging
here from the ceiling fixture
you are the ones who drove me to this
i was doing just fine until you [ __ ]
came along
i hope you're happy now that i'm goddamn
dead
sign the corpse in this room
p.s [ __ ] you people
[Music]
you